[Music]  [Music]  all right let's get you plugged in with  E or is it wifey why don't we just go in  and we are online  I'm going to the super-excited  is one minor thing what is the internet  holy cow look at all this stuff these 10  child stars went to prison number six  will amaze you  redirected to ebay ladies and gentlemen  the next item up a black velvet painting  of a sorrowful kitten it's like it's  looking into my soul yeah that one's  really gonna haunt me for a while  [Music]  no see good I don't understand why  people like this game  raised in milkshake pick the kitty for a  little Maya  no the kitty gets the milkshake the  bunny okay  [Music]  [Music]